troubling news about tv personality and
r b singer
tamar braxton she is under medical
supervision
after a possible suicide attempt i'm not
playing russian roulette with my life
anymore
perry the drama-filled trailer for
tamar's new show get your life
dropped yesterday i've been feeling
choked
about nine hours later tamar was
transported to a hospital
after being found unconscious at a
downtown l.a hotel 900 boulevard tamar
had recently been venting on social
media about wetv
she added slave to her twitter name and
earlier this week wrote
are we going to talk about pay 10 years
on the air
we make 75 less than the kardashians
how come there are no villains on that
show and
that's what happens when it's all white
executives having all the power
i will get justice for my family
we spoke to the 43 year old in may she
along with boyfriend david and her
seven-year-old son logan
seemed excited about the future i am
just getting a really really happy good
place i'm one of those women that you
know we never give up
we do whatever it takes it's like
everything is hard but nothing is too
hard
we figure it out tamar is reportedly in
stable condition